welcome back to the final part of my
fascinating uh with author and
astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson is an
electronic Cliffhanger the 10 burning
questions about the universe rapid fires
here we go what was there before the
beginning of the universe everyone asked
this question what's the simple answer
oh I I'm delighted I can respond to you
we don't know but we got top people
working on it okay you know what there
may have been a Multiverse I like that I
like the honesty so we genuinely don't
know people just don't know right
we don't know there might have been a
Multiverse that's birthing universes and
we're one of them but that just pushes
the question one step further before
that what was around before the
Multiverse so we just don't know it's a
frontier question right now how will the
universe end and what will there be
afterwards
we have several ideas for how it will
end one it will just continue to expand
forever as the temperature descends
asymptotically towards absolute zero and
all phenomenon and all processes will
cease All Stars will burn out they will
shut off in the night sky one by one and
the universe will be cold and dark
but if the expansion of the universe
which is rapid and accelerating is real
and continues that'll take us to the big
grip which we may have talked about on
Monday's visit that terrifies me because
if the fabric of the universe stretches
faster than the [ __ ] then the material
substance can sustain it then it rips
into the uh oh so that's in 22 bill
that's in 22 billion years
of that conversation was it takes 22
billion years to happen right will we in
the next hundred years live on the moon
or Mars or any other planet other than
planet Earth human beings
uh it's not that we can't do it not that
we couldn't figure out to do it we'd
have to ask what is your motivation to
do it do you realize Antarctica
is wetter and balmier than every spot on
Mars surface and you don't see people
lining up to build condos in Antarctica
so I can see them as tourist
destinations I'll totally take a tour to
and have maybe the moon Olympics that'd
be fun okay and a moon chefs Chef's uh
shows but and the joke I always like
telling and it never gets old for me is
like the new cuisine on the moon and
restaurants would be great it's just
that they wouldn't have any atmosphere
hahaha
that's brilliantly terrible that joke
um is the universe infinite and if not
what's on the other side of it
so the observable universe has a
boundary it's not a physical boundary
it's a it's a it's a it's a consequence
of how fast it light travels and how old
the universe is so that sets a horizon a
ship at Sea there's a horizon is is this
is the ship captain saying
is this all there is or does the ocean
go on and they know from their
experience the ocean continues we're
pretty sure the Universe goes well
beyond our Horizon we don't know how far
and it's possibly infinite and if it is
infinite then it wouldn't make sense to
talk about an edge no then the second
question becomes Superfluous is time
travel possible
we can definitely travel into the future
by moving faster relative to everybody
else
um and then you'll come back less aged
than those you left here the tricky part
yeah the tricky part comes if you want
to go into the past and that's really
dangerous it is so dangerous that
Hawking was thinking to himself that
there must be some law of physics we
have yet to discover that prevents it
physically it's called a time travel
protection conjecture right where
because if you go back and prevent your
parents from meeting each other then you
will never be born to go back in time to
prevent your parents from meeting each
other and this whole thing with the
Terminator movie where he's killing
everybody who might give birth to to the
whose person is going to overthrow the
the regime all they have to do is
prevent people from meeting each other
or have them have sex 10 minutes later
or earlier than they might have
otherwise and a different sperm would
have fertilized the egg you got a
different person this won't shoot him it
was so needlessly violent
um so yeah it might not be likely that
we can do this but there are equations
in the general relativity that allow it
we just Hawking just wondered whether
we'll come up to a boundary a rule that
says nope nope the equation tells us but
a higher understanding of the universe
might actually prevent it
parallel universes do they exist
or our current understanding of how this
universe got here tells us there are
plenty of other universes and that's the
Multiverse idea and parallel universe
sounds a little more cool than just
other universes in a Multiverse but sure
then there's likely an infinite number
of them
hence the possibility that I'm
interviewing you on my show from London
and you're here in the you know all
combinations of all atoms and molecules
and thoughts and neurosynaptic firings
would exist in the infinite universes
that are out there you've actually
suggested it I think you suggested it's
just they could be a parallel universe
where dreams are reality and reality is
a dreams
yeah yeah or where stars are gazing down
at you rather than you casing up at the
start you can there's a lot of
variations in this and some of these
universes would have it slightly
different laws of physics so you don't
want to visit them without full
understanding of the consequences of
that you don't want to collapse into a
pile of goo because the molecular forces
that previously held your body together
in this universe don't work in the other
universe that would be a dangerous
dangerous freeways to take okay is there
anyone else out there professor
uh anyone you mean just life at all yes
probably we are made of the most common
ingredients in the universe hydrogen
oxygen nitrogen carbon iron this stuff
is everywhere in the universe life on
Earth was opportunistic it didn't take
the rare ingredients and figure out what
it could do the most common ingredients
and life started almost as quickly as it
possibly could have
and we just one planet out of eight get
over it eight planets and one star among
hundreds of billions in a galaxy among
hundreds of billions to suggest that we
are alone in the universe would be
inexcusably egocentric driven by some
philosophy that is not grounded in
observational science
what's inside a black hole
do you want to go find out oh no we
think we know what is the short answer
we don't have
okay okay
so we have our equations tell us what's
in a black hole but we've never tested
this just so you know so it tells us
that within a black hole the a whole new
space time can open up
in the future history of this universe
and for by that reasoning we in this
universe may be the other side of a
black hole that lives in somebody else's
universe so that is perhaps the most
intriguing part of the equations that
give us black holes what's the most
important thing that most of us don't
know about the universe that we should
for me it's the greatest gift that
modern astrophysics has given
civilization in 1957 a research paper
was published including a leading female
scientist by the way who's under
celebrated maybe one day will get a good
biographer for her name is Margaret
Burbidge but anyway they published a
paper
demonstrating that the that the atoms in
your body the nitrogen the iron the
carbon that all of this are traceable to
Cosmic crucibles deep in the centers of
stars that it makes it manufactures them
by thermonuclear Fusion the star
explodes
gathers that enrichment into gas clouds
that make the next generation of star
systems such as we so it's not like
you're out in the universe looking up
and you say yeah I'm alive in this
universe but I feel small no the
universe is alive within you
and you should feel large
that Revelation that we are not
poetically but literally Stardust
borders on the spiritual and I think
everyone it's it is their duty to know
that to be honest that is very well
aware that I am Stardust for a long time
Professor just to clarify yeah
just don't sweep you into the dust bin
you know we just
throw away my final quick fire question
for you of the ten uh what is your
favorite fact about the universe of the
unbelievably large number of facts you
must have ascertained along with your
scientist colleagues what's the number
one fact that you love most
I am astonished
every day I wake up
that the universe
is knowable
even on the small scales that we've the
nuts that we've cracked for it that it's
knowable at all that we are just you
know billion year old carbon as as Joni
Mitchell puts in her song Woodstock we
can rise to Consciousness and pose
questions about our origin it's been
suggested that we are a way for the
universe to know itself
but the fact that the universe is
knowable at all to me
is stupefying because who said it had to
be that way that we measure laws on
Earth and they are the same as they are
in the heavens
it enables my profession in the first
place
but I'll end with this thought that as
the area of our knowledge grows
so too does the perimeter of our
ignorance
so this might be a never-ending Journey
so the more we know the more stupid we
get is that the bottom line
you got to say it more poetically than
that just
put it out there like that